i was born in ethiopia i joined sporting
casey when i was 12. sporting is a big
deal you know
mls at such a young age it was hard to
be away from my family
i was nervous a lot of emotions
especially the sacrifices i've had to
make
it's very competitive and in everything
we do we're all fighting for a spot
i was gonna quit i thought i was like
too young and too big of a gap
hopefully i'll keep going i think each
training session you gotta take those
little risks to get out of your comfort
zone
and you just need to play soccer
the academy is the homegrown player
development program of sporting kansas
city
every young player recruited to join is
competing for the chance to sign a
professional contract
in major league soccer and a place on
the first team roster the competition
for these young athletes is fierce
and with the onset of covet 19 the
stakes have never been higher
you're not talking about just creating a
soccer player you're talking about
creating the whole person
the academy is where these players first
start so being able to give them
the proper whether it is development on
the field
off the field we look after to make sure
that how do they function
not only in their home life but what if
we have kids that are coming in our
residency program
how are they functioning in that
environment because they're not living
with their
with their parents because maybe they're
living they've moved here from a
different state
a company an organization like audi it
makes the world of difference
in having a you know a pretty good
academy
to having a world-class academy the
players that are coming through the
system
are better prepared than i was and then
my generation when you look at what audi
is trying to do
whether it's housing whether it's
education whether it's transportation
all three of those things are going to
fill the gaps in trying to find
the best players
i joined the sporting academy
in august 2017. i didn't honestly know
what i was really walking into
all i looked at it was you know i'm
going to a new team
i'm going to be living with a host
family it was a whole it was like moving
to a whole new world
my mom she sends me a lot of stuff it's
kind of nice but
you know just pictures and little frames
and stuff like that
i think a lot of us move to the academy
also sacrifice having a normal
teenage life you know it's a lot of
traveling like it's almost like being a
little mini pro
i think our training sessions have
altered a little bit also because
social distancing um non-contact type of
drills so we're alternating those feet
when we're juggling niko
they lego good night
i'm 15 years old and i've been in the
academy for
five years i've been playing all my life
since i was since i could walk
i was just more happy to get out of
the orphanage where i was and to come
here i think it's
great opportunities for each and every
one of us we've had these technical
trainings that are like on the zoom that
will help us
and we do like extra stuff on our own
just to try to get better i think it's
been
just a little bit difficult because i
really miss the game
and seeing the guys there
twice a week we all sit on a call with
them and
you know they will show videos but also
get up and do
technical stuff and so the players will
go along with it and we do it in small
groups
so we can stay focused and critique the
players and help them out
we'll come back you know a day or two
later and
we'll go through those technical
exercises and add more to it
our pathway is extremely clear you know
we have the academy
we have the usl you know the b team and
then we have the first team
and you see players actually
matriculating through it
and progressing through the pro pathway
and getting the opportunity with the
first team
so i was playing for uh the academy in
north carolina that's where i started
playing soccer and
a lot of mls teams would you know come
and try to scout guys i didn't really
think that much about i was like hey i'm
going to play soccer
you know i was by myself and i was like
wait what did i just do you know i
should actually
you know move halfway across the country
and i'm buying myself a 14 year old
so that's kind of when the decision hit
me like okay i actually did this
i think the academy played a huge part
in you know making that that jump
to the first team a lot easier because
yeah you know the
the talent's obviously not going to be
the same level as professional it's the
academy the youngest but
they they build the environment the the
exact same as how the professionals do
it
get back you know to training and
everything i'm gonna be so excited i'm
just gonna you know
you know play so hard just press
back playing again that's something i
love to do so really you know everybody
wants to be pro
obviously becoming a pro is just
improving like
getting becoming the best i can be the
love for the game
and my family having them not to work
anymore i want that to be my goal and i
feel like i can
achieve that by becoming pro
the goal that i have for every player in
the academy regardless of if they turn
pro or if they don't
is to become the best version of
themselves i just think about the
academy
it hasn't really helped me as a player
for the sporting kansas city
organization
it helps me in you know life outside of
soccer too it teaches you how to open
how to overcome adversity and when
things aren't going your way
how are you going to react and how are
you going to deal with what's at your
at your feet you know it's obviously not
advice i've gotten but i think it's like
a lesson i've learned out of the academy
[Applause]
ambition is a great thing right to have
ambition is
unbelievable it's what it's what gets
you to where you want to go
well you need to conquer all the other
things along the way to get there so
that when you get there you can be
successful
a couple my coaches always told me
don't be casual still go your hardest so
keep pushing
to the limit every day we believe in the
young
guys we believe in our system i want to
see their progression
if the player truly is committed
to the pathway there's going to be a
player or two
that nobody knows but because of the
platform they're given
right now in the exposure to higher
learning
and higher quality they're going to be
playing in a world cup for the united
states and all of us are going to look
at each other and say
where did he come from
[Music]
[Music]
as academy players continue to train
remotely sporting kc looks forward to
the day when they once again
reconvene on the field next time on the
academy
we'll see the players return to life in
kansas city where they'll face a brand
new set of challenges as they continue
to chase down their dreams both on and
off the field